okay there's one more feature of complex
numbers that i want to share with you
and we'll do that down here
so our definition of j is
j squared
equals minus 1. and now what i want to
do is a sequence of multiplications
by j this is a this is a really
important property of this this
imaginary unit
we do powers of j and i'm going to plot
them while we're doing that i want to
plot them on the imaginary
or on the complex plane
so this is the real axis and this is the
imaginary axis
so i'm going to take powers of j so
first one is j to the zero and anything
to the zero is one so j to the zero is
one and if we plot that on the imaginary
axis here's here's one
and there's no real part
so we're just right on the the real axis
okay let's do j to the one
that's j times itself one time and so
that is equal to j
if i plot that number
that's up here
that's up on the imaginary
axis right there there's j
alright this has no real part it's all
imaginary
okay let's keep going let's do j squared
and what does that equal to well i wrote
it down up here j squared is equal to
minus 1.
so j squared is equal to minus 1.
where's that in the complex plane that's
over here
at minus 1.
on the real axis no imaginary part
let's do the next one let's do j
cubed what is that equal to
j to the third power
is equal to
j squared times j
and we have those two right here
j squared is minus one
and j to the one is j
so that equals minus j
and where do we plot that we plot that
down on the imaginary axis in the
complex plane
right here minus j okay now we've got
four answers let's do one or two more
okay j to the fourth
is equal to what it's equal to
j squared times j squared
let's look that up it's minus 1 times -1
and what does that equal to that equals
1.
so let's go plot that well we've already
plotted it so that's that's this answer
right here
all right so we already have that let's
do one more
j to the fifth what does that equal to
that equals j to the fourth
times j
and j to the fourth is right here it's
one times j
equals
j
let's go plot that one
well we've already plotted it it's
already right here
okay so
you can see there's a pattern here
1 j minus 1 minus j
1 j it's going to be -1 and minus j it
keeps repeating
here's what's interesting about this
okay if we draw this as vectors if i
draw these
imaginary numbers as vectors
when i multiplied by j when i multiplied
one by j
it rotated it 90 degrees
and then that was the first step right
here when i multiplied 1 times j
i got j
now when we went to j squared we ended
up at -1 so multiplying by j again
caused the vector to go down here
like that and that was another 90
degrees
and if i take it again the next one went
this way
and the final one went this way
so this is the property of j this is the
key property of the imaginary unit
multiplying by the imaginary unit
is the nature of it is this 90 degree
rotation there's this idea of
a number that causes other numbers to
rotate and that's the feature of j
that makes it super important and it's
the reason that we use imaginary numbers
in electrical engineering
so the key idea here is that j
rotates
that's the point that's what we love
about j
so the last thing i want to mention is
the negative powers of j what happens if
we have j to the minus one
let's figure out what that means so that
of course is
one over j
and if i multiply this by j
over j and anything over itself is one
so i haven't changed the value of this
and that equals
j on top over
j times j or j squared
and what is j squared equal to
we wrote it down right here j squared is
minus 1.
so this equals j
over
minus 1
or equals
minus j
so whenever we see j in a fraction j to
the minus one basically it introduces a
minus sign and the j comes up to the top
out of the fraction
so
j to the minus one
equals minus j
and we'll use that occasionally to help
us in our in our math
so this was a really quick review
of complex numbers and if any of this
was new to you i really encourage you to
go back and watch sal's videos on
complex numbers and if this is something
you've seen before i hoped it knocked
off some of the rust and we're ready to
go
and use these numbers